في هذا الوقت
العصيب
الذي تفرض قيامنا
الانسانيه علاقاتنا
القديمه
المستمره حرصنا على ان
نحمي كل شعوب منطقتنا من ويلاه العنف
والحرب ان نعمل معا وبشكل غير منقطع
لانهاء هذه
الكارثه التي تفجرت في السابع
من شهر تشرين اول الماضي وتدهورت الى
الحرب التي تشنها اسرائيل على غزه
الان حديثنا اليوم كان صريحا كان مباشرا
كان شاملا وكان
معمقا و
بشفافيه عكس مواقف عربيه وامريكيه متباينه
فيما يتعلق بما يجب فعله
فوريا لانهاء هذه الكارثه لكنه اكد ايضا
الحرص المشترك على استمرار انخراطنا بشكل
مكثف لوقف ما لا يمكن الا ان نصفه بكارثه
ستسكن
كوابيسها المنطقه لاجيال وعلى اننا كلنا
نريد السلامه العادله والشامله على اساس
حل الدولتين سبيلا لضمان امن المنطقه ضمان
امن الفلسطينيين امن الاسرائيليين وامن كل
شعوب
منطقتنا كان هنالك ايضا نقاط التقاء وهذه
نقاط التقاء اقصد
بين الموقف الامريكي والموقف الذي عبر عنه
وزراء الخارجيه العرب الذين كانوا في
الاجتماع شملت هذه النقاط ضروره ايصال
الدعم الانساني الكافي والفوري والمستدام
الى ال غزه استئناف تقديم الخدمات
الانسانيه حمايه المدنيين ضروره التزام
القانون الدولي والقانون الدولي الانساني
اطلاق المدنيين ورفض تهجير الفلسطينيين من
وطنهم وكما قلنا سابق سابقا هذا بالنسبه
لاشقائنا في جمهوريه مصر العربيه ولنا في
الاردن ولكل الدول العربيه جريمه حرب اخرى
سنتصدى لها بكل
طاقاتنا في الدول العربيه نطالب بوقف فوري
لاطلاق النار وانهاء هذه الحرب وما تنتجه
من قتل الابرياء وما تسببه من دمار
ونرفض توصيفها دفاعا عن النفس هي حرب
مستعره تقتل المدنيين تدمر بيوتهم
مستشفياتهم مدارسهم مساجدهم كنائسهم ولا
يمكن تبريرها ولن تجلب لاسرائيل امنا ولن
تحقق في المنطقه
سلاما القتل يجب ان
يتوقف جرائم الحرب يجب ان تتوقف تحصين
اسرائيل من القانون الدولي ايضا يجب ان
ينتهي لقد حرست خلال اللقاء على توضيح
رؤيه مصر المتوافقه مع رؤيه اشقائها العرب
في التعامل مع الازمه واكدت على ضروره
مراعاه عناصر عنصر الوقت التعامل مع
مستجداتها المتسارعه وان احداث القتل
المؤسفه التي تشهدها غزه لا يمكن تبريرها
واننا لن نقبل الدخول في جدل لا طائل منه
او قبول محاوله تبرير هذه الممارسات
المدان باعتبارها اعمالا للحق الشرعي
الدفاع عن
النفس سياسه العقاب الجماعي واستهداف
اسرائيل للمدنيين
والابرياء
والمنشات المدنيه والطبيه وفرق الانقاذ
الاضافه لمحاولات التهجير القصري
للفلسطينيين من ارضهم لا يمكن ان تكون
دفاعا شرعيا عن النفس باي حال ان مصر تبذل
كل ما في وسعها لضمان استقبال المساعدات
وادخالها الى قطاع غزه وتقديم العون في
علاج الجرحى المدنيين
وستستمر في جهودها ذات الصله رغم العراقيل
الكبيره والمتعمد التي
تواجهها وفي هذا السياق ادت على حتميه
تحقيق توافق فوري
وشامل وقف فوري وشامل لاطلاق النار في غزه
دون قيد او شرط وان تقلع اسرائيل عن
مخالفاتها المتكرره لقواعد القانون الدولي
الانساني وقوانين الح حرب ومضاعفه العمل
لتامين نفاذ المساعدات الانسانيه بصوره
مستدامه وبالكميات التي تلبي احتياجات
الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق وبما يفتح المجال
للحديث لاحقا عن كيفيه الخروج من هذه
الازمه وقبل ان تتسع دائره العنف وامتداد
الصراع ليطال امن واستقرار سائر شعوب
المنطقه ويدخلها في نفق
مزلم كما ا كدت خلال اجتماعنا على ضروره
الكف عن التعامل مع القضايا والازمات التي
تهدد السلم والامن الدوليين بمعايير
مزدوجه ففي حين يسارع البعض في ادانه
استهداف المدنيين ووصف الاعتداءات عليهم
بالانتهاكات الصارخه للقانون الدولي
الانساني والتمسك بمطالب وقف اطلاق النار
في ازمات اخرى اننا نشهد معارضه التزام
بذات المبادئ نفس الا الاطراف حينما يرتبط
الامر بالقضيه الفلسطينيه وكان دم الانسان
العربي اقل قيمه من دم اخيه الانسان في
اماكن اخرى علما بان اعداد من ازهقت
ارواحهم من المدنيين في غزه على مدار
الاسابيع القليله الماضيه وضمنهم العاملين
في مجال الاغاثه والصحفيين لا يمكن
تبريرها ي ذريعه او ادعام وفي هذا الصدد
اننا مازلنا ططلب بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار
وبتوقف اسرائيل عن تعطيل دخول المساعدات
الانسانيه وضمان النفاذ الامن والسريع لها
كما نطلب التحقيق الدولي في ممارسات
والانتهاكات الصارخه للقانون الدولي التي
تشهدها هذه الحرب واخيرا فان ما نشهده من
تصعيد غير مسبوق وماساه انسانيه ومن
معاناه المدنيين انما هو نتيجه
التقاعس عن معالجه جذور المشكله وتاخر
استعاده الحقوق الفلسطينيه غير القابله
للتصرف واذا انني اكرر اليوم الرفض القاطع
لاي محاولات لتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه على
حساب الشعب الفلسطينيه او دول المنطقه
انني اطالب مجددا بالعمل على في اسرع وقت
ممكن على احياء عمليه السلام وفقا لحل
الدولتين في سبيل انهاء احتلال الاسرائيلي
تكسيد الدوله الفلسطينيه على خطوط الرابع
من يونيو لعام
1967 وعاصمتها القد
الشرقيه
throughout conflict countries across
mid e and
beed ro inting spre to we all agreed on
the importance of using influence and
capabilities
to
inc flow human
gaz
egy isra united
[موسيقى]
nation more trucks ra
up that
near
we about ways toate
andain
delivery morning i had opportunity to
meet with comm
general unra and i spoke with unra staff
that is located in gaza i heard about
the extraordinary saav work they doing
in gaza in the face of extrem difficult
condition and how we cans to ass to them
so they can get to the palestinian
people also working to continue the
progress we made in getting our cz other
for critically wounded people out of
gaza but even as we welcome their safe
exit we remain resolutely committed and
focus securing the release hostages h by
hamas i the opportunity discuss this the
status of our ons with prim min morning
we
toar need to protect
united
stat
att
palestin
future this
isri
isct do
it
is
mys isra offals yest i
conec civ help hur exp
sit
most the right
moral
i
palan
girl
any